there's nothing quite like a good kiss
to break a heart or two as fans of these
shows will tell you
whether it's a tragic farewell a
shocking betrayal or even a chance to
save a life
each kiss easily ranks among the
greatest tear-jerking moments in tv
history
few shows managed to throw more tragic
obstacles between a couple than a good
place
heck the fact that eleanor and chidi's
relationship survives past that
horrifying clown bed to begin with is a
testament to their deep bond
but through reboot after reboot the pair
continually finds their way back to each
other giving fans some hope that true
love does in fact endure
sadly all good things must come to an
end at least for a while that is
by the later seasons of the good place
eleanor and chidi just aren't themselves
unless they're sacrificing their
happiness to save not only the world but
the afterlife too
so it only fits that the season 3 finale
sees the pair wipe chidi's memory to
save the good place and the souls of all
humanity for good
as if that weren't enough to tuck at the
heartstrings demon turned good guy
michael sets up a greatest hits montage
of chidi and eleanor's moments
throughout their hundreds of reboots
of course eleanor can't help lighten the
mood i know you're deflecting by making
jokes about how high
it's not a joke i'm a legit snack but
there are tears all around when she
kisses chidi and the season goodbye
the brutal blow of this not so final
kiss between eleanor and chidi is only
softened by the knowledge that in the
end these two get the happy ending they
deserve however bittersweet it may be
supernatural's dean and joe had a will
they won't they vibe from the moment she
showed up in season 2
but dean was careful not to cross the
line however dean's self-restraint gets
thrown out the window and abandon all
hope when the apocalypse comes
again and for the first time ever dean
tries unsuccessfully to pick someone up
sweetheart if this is our last night on
earth and i'm going to spend it with a
little thing i call self-respect
clearly surprised at being rebuffed dean
finally sees joe as an equal and a
genuine potential match
sadly hell hath no fury like a hellhound
scorned
while the hunter's brigade attempts to
kill lucifer joe's guts end up as puppy
child
knowing she's on death's door she
decides to sacrifice herself in a
supernaturally charged blast to give the
winchesters an open shot at lucifer
with regret and grief in his eyes dean
kisses joe on the forehead but it isn't
enough
teasing what their relationship could
have been he passionately kisses her
before tearing himself away to have a
few words with the devil
the kicker all that sacrifice is for not
not even samuel colt's gun can take out
the root of all evil and joe and her
mother ellen die in vain
talk about a cruel farewell criminal
minds isn't known for killing off its
main characters too often but the death
of hatch's wife haley was one of the
most shocking moments in the show's
history
and while fans love to hate the episode
it's hard to argue that it isn't one of
the most brilliant of the whole series
chilling and gut wrenching sure but
brilliant later as hotch is fighting for
his own life in the hospital he meets up
with haley in a trance-like vision
they watch her son's home videos at a
theater and apparent homage to watching
over someone after death
haley then convinces him to move on and
be happy because it just isn't his time
to die
after years of tormenting himself with
blame still full of love and light
haley tells him that it's okay she lets
him go with a kiss in her ring
promising to always love him whether the
vision was real or hatch's coma adult
imagination the scene provides beautiful
closure for her tragic yet somehow
hopeful arc
lgbtq plus relationships often meet
tragic ends on tv while the one thing
going for the walking dead in this case
is the show's general propensity to kill
off pretty much everyone anyhow
eric and aaron were already dating when
the walkers began taking over
and even the coming of the walking dead
couldn't tear them apart surprisingly
eric's death isn't the result of the
undead but a group of survivors called
the saviors aaron pleads for him to keep
going making it all that much more
painful to watch
you know i love you
you know i'm right finally realizing
that his boyfriend's death is inevitable
aaron kisses eric goodbye
and fans are left to pick up the pieces
of their shattered hearts
even worse aaron leaves eric to die
without killing him allowing his
boyfriend to become a member of the
undead
most doctor who fans tend to prefer rose
and the tenth doctor as a couple to rose
and the ninth doctor but the fateful
kiss that causes nine's regeneration
into ten
is the spark that lights their love
story and changes the course of the
series forever
the writers made the bold but inevitable
move to kill off nine who was the first
doctor featured in the show's 2005
revival once actor christopher
ecclestone decided to leave the show but
it's a bit dodgy this process
you never know what you're going to end
up with and so thanks to the creative
differences with eckelstone and the
needs of an epic save the world story
the minute rose and nine locked lips
marks the end of nine's existence
all the compelling darkness and grief
that christopher eccleston had brought
to the usually vivacious doctor was lost
after just one season
this sense of inevitability and
melancholy permeates the whole episode
making the final kiss between rose and
nine both cathartic and tragic
sadly it is to date the last time the
ninth doctor has appeared on screen
outside of stock footage as the drama
between ecclestone and doctor who's
producers continued for years after he
left the show
buffy and angel are the poster children
for tragic first love
vampire in love with the slayer
it's rather poetic in a modern sort of
way
in simpler terms their relationship is
doomed as all hell over the course of
the show buppy and angel have seen their
fair share of tragic farewells but none
of their goodbyes are as cruel as the
season 2 finale
buffy ends up in a battle for angel soul
after their participation in a few
minutes of bad
touch gives angel one moment of
happiness to many causing him to be
transformed into the nefarious villain
known as angelus
after going on a rampage things get a
little out of hand and angelus opens a
portal to hell
while buffy succeeds in bringing back
angel it's too late by that point and
the only way to close the portal is to
chuck him right in
so in tears buffy kisses her vampire
lover one more time before stabbing him
as the portal sucks him in
and she loses her first love forever
well not forever but for a while
michael and sarah just can't catch a
break as they're always continually torn
apart whenever they find a moment to be
happy
given that the show is called prison
break no one expected the innocent
fugitive michael to stay free for long
after escaping during the first season
so where did they go from there well he
ended up in prison
again and was forced to break out again
yeah it's a little convoluted but it's
kind of the whole point of the show
where michael's girlfriend sarah kills a
rogue fbi agent panama she has a fairly
understandable breakdown
so michael makes the impulsive decision
to fake taking her hostage at gunpoint
when they get caught
they also both exchange verbal i love
yous for the first time
sealing the declaration with a desperate
kiss you sacrificed everything for me
once
no don't move now it's time to say thank
you
as sarah frantically protests michael
takes the blame for the killing and is
subsequently arrested and imprisoned
the next season the writers rode out a
pregnant sarah by shipping her
character's decapitated head to lincoln
a move that wasn't exactly warmly
received by fans
they later retconned that particular arc
after the same fans demanded her return
with emails and boycotts
but it doesn't make michael's premature
goodbye kiss any less heartbreaking
dealing with loss is hard enough when it
happens on one occasion but grey's
anatomy likes to dole out death blows
like candy
in izzy's case after losing her love
denny wants she loses him all over again
when she herself is on the brink of
death
izzy initially watches denny die when he
suffers from a stroke after a heart
transplant surgery
still he lives on to haunt her in her
mind which makes sense as she cut his
lvad device against his will to move him
up the transplant list risking losing
her medical license
when izzy suffers from cancer symptoms
she hallucinates denny for a while
believing he's a ghost
as she kisses him one last time he
disappears into thin air ripping them
apart yet again
and leaving her more lost and confused
than ever fans will never quite know
whether denny was spiritually there or
if it was just a hallucination
it's hard not to feel for izzy given all
that she's been through but the true
tragedy lies with denny and her refusal
to let him go
which may be the real reason she lost
him in the first place
game of thrones easily wins the award
for forging more family connections than
any of its characters really ought to
have
and that's definitely the case for
princess marcelo whose uncle jaime
lannister is also her father
now game of thrones fans meet many of
the series's deaths with ambivalence or
even celebration but princess marcelo's
demise was nothing less than
heartbreaking
luckily or unluckily the princess's
mother cersei is no stranger to revenge
jenna marcella's case her kiss of death
happens twice
because her mother is kind of the worst
marcella is forced to flee dorne and go
back to king's landing after her life is
threatened
still hoping to avenge prince oberyn
however the nefarious elaria sand dons a
fierce shade of poisonous lipstick and
kisses marcelo before the young princess
leaves
only ellaria has the antidote of course
and marcella is basically doomed from
the moment she leaves
aboard the ship home jaime who's
accompanying her home reveals that he's
also her father
she admits she's always had a hunch
accepting him anyway
marcella's nose begins to bleed and it
becomes clear that something has gone
very wrong indeed
jaime cradles marcella as she dies and
not even the incestuous reveal is enough
to take away the ironic shakespearean
tragedy of it all
as one of the only genuinely innocent
characters in the series her brutal
death stands out as particularly cruel
and unfair
marcello's death doesn't go unavenged
however and ellaria also gets her just
desserts
in the form of a poisonous kiss to her
daughter courtesy of cersei
but hey that's life in westeros for ya
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one